I'm suspicious of the timing of it I'm
also aware of the fact that things can
be planted on people
places and things can be planted
things things can be planted in places
or good afternoon or good evening
depending on where you are it's January
16th here in the United States in the
year 2023 we are live streaming on
Rumble YouTube and we'll be doing a post
game show on locals later if you have
not already shared subscribed and tap
notification Bells accordingly please go
ahead and do that and we got a big show
for you on this Monday it is rare that
on a Sunday
I email my guys work related things I
try to let these people live their lives
on the weekends but last night
at about nine o'clock I was doing my
quick little review you know I try not
to spend too much time on Twitter over
the weekend but then at some point
during during Sunday I have to look a
little bit so I can send some stuff to
my guys so we can start by Monday
morning figuring out what we're going to
do on Mondays but last night I was
reviewing what's going on in the world
seeing some of the Sunday talk show
nonsense and all that stuff and I
thought I know exactly what I want to do
with the show today I really want to do
a destruction of Joe Biden I know that
Joe Biden has been doing a destruction
of himself and his wife Dr Joe Biden on
Dr Jill Biden has unfortunately not uh
diagnosed him with whatever's going on
there but the the walls seem to be
closing in as they say on Poor Joe the
elderly man pretending to be president
and I don't think this is going to end
well it seems to me that between the
hunter Biden scandal between this
classified document Scandal between the
obvious cognitive problems and the
general state of the country there is
every reason right now for the machine
to exit Joe Biden and to figure out who
the next thing is going to be whether
whether it's going to be Gavin Newsom or
somebody else so we're going to do a
kind of a little expose on some of the
problems that Joe is having and then I
will lay out my thoughts on what really
will happen after all this at the end so
let's start with some of the general
criminality of the Biden family because
look you guys know you get it we've
talked about it while nobody else was
allowed to talk about it or while they
wouldn't let you talk about on Twitter
this Hunter Biden laptop thing and how
it was connected directly to Joe and it
all felt like some sort of money
laundering thing because Hunter Biden
was working for this Ukrainian Energy
company making 80 grand a month even
though he had no expertise in energy so
it obviously had something to do with
the fact that his dad was vice president
at the time on top of the crack smoking
and all the sex trafficking and the
prostitutes and all of that stuff so
anyway Senator Ron Johnson from
Wisconsin was on Meet the Press
yesterday with Chuck Todd Chuck Todd is
you know it's hard to say that someone
is sort of the worst television
personality out there the worst
quote-unquote corporate journalist Chuck
Todd really leveled up yesterday in in
being the swampiest
smuggest just absolutely I am not here
to do journalism I am clearly here to
protect certain people and Destroy other
people that is Chuck Todd's job that's
what it should say under his name so Ron
Johnson Republican obviously he's on
with Chuck Todd they're talking about
the criminality of the Biden's Hunter
Biden laptop and much more listen to how
Chuck Todd frames this question and then
watch body language and a bunch more we
got a couple clips for you do you have a
crime that you think Hunter Biden
committed because I've yet to see
anybody explain it is not a crime to
make money off your last name
so Chuck you ought to read the Marco
Polo report where they detail all kinds
of potential crimes you know Senator
grass
potential
about about 30
000 about thirty thousand dollars
chuck chuck is it a crime to be uh
soliciting and purchasing uh
prostitution in potentially European sex
trafficking operations is that a crime
because Chuck grass and I laid out about
thirty thousand dollars uh paid by
Hunter Biden to those types of of
individuals over uh December 2018 2019
about thirty thousand dollars this is
about the same time that President Biden
offered to pay about a hundred thousand
dollars of Hunter Biden's bills I mean
again that's that's just some
information I I don't know exactly but I
don't care all right it doesn't doesn't
really look on the it sounds sleazy as
you know I mean do I even have to
analyze that like his his smugness his
dismissiveness the very way he frames
the question it's all to defend Biden
like I don't know how much more of
evidence we are going to need to prove
like case clothes that you people carry
water for Democrats and you only try to
destroy Republicans I mean two very
simple versions of this uh that he says
you know he's it a crime to use your
family name do you think he would have
said that if this was about Donald Trump
Jr so if we were just to reverse say
three years ago or so and there was a
scandal around Donald Trump Jr do you
think chuck would be saying that defense
well he's just a trump that doesn't mean
he's guilty about anything no of course
he wouldn't have done that and they
would never Grant Trump this wide leash
that they are granting Joe Biden right
now right like it's just oh well he's
sort of incompetent or we don't really
know or anything else and just his his
faux outrage and all of it it really is
just I mean it really you could probably
watch that with the with the audio off
and you would already understand really
what's going on there uh here is more
here is Ron Johnson basically being
gaslit by Chuck Todd about media
partisanship and bias as I've been
saying lately the Republicans are
growing balls and it's freaking people
out
I I'm I'm concerned about getting the
truth I don't talk individuals Target
individuals you're targeting 100.
you're targeting an individual my
concern you know Chuck you know part of
the problem and this is pretty obvious
to anybody watching this is you don't
invite me on to interview me you invite
me on to argue with me you know I'm just
trying to lay out the facts that
certainly Senator grass and I uncovered
they were suppressed they were censored
they interfered in the 2020 election
conservatives understand that
unfortunately liberals in the media
don't and that's part of the things that
part of the reasons our politics are
inflamed is we do not have an unbiased
uh media we don't it's unfortunate I'm
all for free press more unbiased there's
misinformation
look you can go back on your partisan
cable a cocoon and talk about media by
saw you on I understand it's part of
your identity let me move to what
Chuck Todd man you are terrible
you are absolutely terrible Chuck Todd I
don't pretend to be a journalist I don't
I suppose at some level some version of
what I'm doing here has something to be
something related to journalism but what
I am doing is I am trying to see what's
going on out into the world trying to
give people an honest assessment of it
not hiding what my biases are I
obviously tell you what my opinions are
and it's very clear what he does as a
quote journalist this is someone who
pretends to be a journalist he works at
a giant Corporation he puts on his suit
he points with the pen and he pretends
that he is unbiased so at the end there
you go back to your biased cocoon oh you
are the biased cocoon man it's just that
mirror thing that I keep talking about
these people just need a mirror
everything they accuse everyone else of
is exactly what they're guilty of Ron
Johnson was just laying out facts there
here's what we know was going on right
here is the fact that we know Hunter
Biden was involved in some level of sex
trafficking because of the information
we found found out on the laptop the
laptop that was censored by big Tech
that you guys all pretended to ignore
that Chuck Todd I have no doubt we can
probably find video on this at the
height of the whole thing there is no
doubt that Chuck Todd was one of the
people promoting that idea that you know
the 50 FBI agents or what was it the 50
CIA operatives Intelligence Officers who
all said it was Russian misinformation
and then of course it was not but all
right I know people don't want to get
totally lost in the weeds of the hunter
Biden laptop still and whether Hunter
was smoking crack and banging hookers or
whatever but there is something that
links this well there's a few things now
that link this directly to Joe Biden so
Dinesh D'Souza had an interesting tweet
here take a look at this and he's he's
retweeting an article uh here's what
Dinesh said about the whole situation
this might be one of the ways Hunter was
fueling funneling money to Joe Biden as
part of the family's 10 for the big guy
agreement and here's what the article
States background check form claims
Hunter Biden paid 50 000 a month month
to rent Biden home where classified docs
were stored so Joe Biden owns the home
where these documents were stored we'll
have more on that in just a second the
garage the relatively unsecured garage
right where there was a Corvette but
it's a garage where these documents were
Hunter Biden was renting it for 50 Grand
a month now first off how did Hunter
Biden a crack addict get 50 Grand a
month well we know he got 80 grand a
month from barisma the Ukrainian Energy
company that he had no business working
at then he gives 50 Grand a month to Joe
Biden 50 Grand a month do you know how
much that is do you know what kind of
house you can rent for 50 Grand a month
go on Zillow or Trulia and tell them
that your your budget is 50 Grand a
month you can live in the sickest house
on the top of the craziest Hill with the
best view you can possibly imagine but
instead he decided to live in Delaware
you know in like a three bedroom house
50 Grand a month so there there is a
picture here that is coming together in
terms of how they laundered the money
right you get the money from verisma you
give the money back for to your dad for
the house for the rental of the house
when the documents happen to be there so
the crack addict was living in the house
with the documents anyway if you want
something a little funny about all this
here's Hunter Biden and Will Ferrell
enjoy how's my protege I went one time
for 13 days without sleeping and smoking
crack and drinking vodka exclusively
throughout that entire career I probably
smoke more parmesan cheese than anyone
what an idiot oh what a loser yeah I uh
I'm abide and we cry too much yeah
I rode my bike over to a cemetery nearby
her boyfriend just died yeah I'll throw
in a wedding every now and then but
funerals are insane overwhelming grief
the chicks are so horny it's not even
fair yeah crazy horny grief turned into
a hope for a love grief is Nature's Most
Powerful aphrodisiac it's like fishing
with dynamite that's what I've learned
trust in the process Saturday I got one
Saturday
you're coming with
how much more evidence do you need you
know what I'm saying people I think you
get it I think you get it the other
thing that I think you get of course is
the is the double standard right if
these people did not have double
standards they would have no standards
so let's just flash back a little bit
we've shown you this video a couple
times but it is worth repeating worth
viewing again uh this is three years ago
when Donald J Trump was president and he
went on 60 Minutes and Leslie Stahl was
interviewing him although it really
wasn't an interview it was a Lynch job
and he started talking about the hunter
Biden laptop now again this is at the
exact same time that you could not tweet
about it that the New York Post was
suspended on Twitter uh where Facebook
went out of their way to stop the links
getting out now knowing right you flash
forward to where we are now we now know
it was all true uh here's Trump and
Leslie Stahl Leslie and do you think
it's the biggest issue to campaign on I
think it's this I think it's one of the
biggest scandals I've ever seen and you
don't cover it you want to talk about
well because it can't be verified you
want to talk about insignificant things
I'm telling you of course it can be
verified excuse me they found the laptop
Leslie Leslie
what can't be verified the laptop why
you said that because even the family
hasn't the family on the laptop
he's gone into hiding for five days he's
gone into hiding he's preparing for your
debate oh it's taken him five days to
prepare I doubt it I doubt it okay
look you just have to understand Trump
was right and the reason I wanted to
show you that clip is because you can
see the way that Chuck Todd was going
after Ron Johnson there is the exact
same way that Leslie Stahl was going
about going after Trump three years ago
right they are playing defense for a
side and then they occasionally played
offense to destroy the other side I
don't know how we could have changed the
narrative on this a whole bunch of us
were screaming that this thing looks
legit like there was no one out there
when the when the laptop got dropped off
at this random repair shop and then
eventually it made its way to Rudy
Giuliani when the guy was like oh man
this seems like something the repair
shop guy
um there was nobody that was legit
saying that it wasn't real they just
start putting these stories out in the
media that it's somehow Russian
disinformation and once I would say your
red pilled as you probably are and I am
it's like I don't buy anything that the
mainstream media tells us about any of
this stuff but Trump really did did try
he tried to get people to understand it
you may remember this moment from I
believe this is from the second debate
that he and Joe Biden did there are 50
50 intelligence folks who said that what
this he's accusing me of is a Russian
plan they have said that this is has all
the Care four five former heads of the
CIA both parties say what he's saying is
a bunch of garbage nobody believes it
except them his and his good friend Rudy
Gianni you mean the laptop is now
another Russia Russia Russia hoax that's
exactly what this is exactly what this
is where he's going the last stop is
Russia I want to stay
you got it guys everything that Joe
Biden said there was a lie those 50
intelligence officials who all said it
was Russian disinformation none of them
are saying that anymore they should all
be shamed into Oblivion one of them was
uh James Clapper uh who of course was
the former head of the CIA who lied
about spying on Americans years ago and
that of course became a CNN contributor
uh there's a whole I think John Brennan
was on there a whole bunch and they all
lied he also talks about five Biden five
former heads of the CIA well it was all
a lie because it was real Trump was
right it was real
but let's talk about stuff that now
we're all in agreement is real we can't
seem to agree on what was real then but
it doesn't it does seem like we're
starting to agree on what's real at
least uh at the moment uh as you guys
know
the classified docs we've got a tweet
here about what's going on Breaking the
second batch of Biden classified
documents were found in a garage storage
space at his home Biden's home in
Wilmington Delaware so this is the home
that Hunter Biden was renting for fifty
thousand dollars a month I assure you it
was not worth fifty thousand dollars a
month and where did the crack addict
porn addict get the money
maybe from the job at the thing that he
wasn't qualified for okay you got it so
it's not just at the think tank right so
he had this Think Tank the UPenn Biden
whatever it was think tank now they're
literally sitting in a garage next to
his car uh here is Biden uh just a
couple months ago when all the documents
were found at Mar-A-Lago uh here is
Biden talking about Trump's uh
incompetence and you saw the photograph
of the top secret documents laid out on
the floor at Mar-A-Lago what did you
think to yourself
looking at that image
how that could possibly happen how one
anyone could be that irresponsible
and I thought what data was in there
that made compromise sources and methods
by that I mean names of people helped or
et cetera and it just uh totally
irresponsible
and you don't know
irresponsible now I get it he's just a
muddled fool nothing he says really
means anything but if we were to apply
his standard to himself
he's in a lot of trouble now you guys
also know we talked about this on Friday
with the panel and Josh Hammer who's a
lawyer I was talking about how the
president does have the ability to
declassify documents Donald Trump was
the president the president can
declassify whatever he wants the vice
president which Joe Biden was at the
time of these documents does not have
such a benefit he does not have the
option to do that the fact that these
documents were there and one of the
things that all the Biden people keep
saying is Well they were just he was
just a small amount of documents and
we're cooperating that that doesn't
there's no that doesn't work that's not
how this works that's not how any of
this works you understand it's a small
amount of documents okay it could be the
most secret [ __ ]
who killed JFK it's on this paper it's a
small amount of documents but this is
seriously important stuff anyway uh one
of the few people in the media who is in
the corporate media I would say who is
fighting and constantly asking the right
questions uh is Peter Ducey over at Fox
News so he asked uh Karen Jean-Pierre on
Thursday about what's going on here
and then on these documents how could
anyone be that irresponsible
it isn't that what this President says
about mishandling classified documents
the president spoke to this personally
he spoke to this personally he again he
believes that
that classified documents and
information should be taken seriously he
takes them seriously and he was
surprised to learn by any any record he
just says absolutely nothing she's so
perfect for this job in in these
whack-a-doodle times that we live in
because she says absolutely nothing she
uses a lot of words and says nothing
right it's just awful because we want
some level of truth but her job is to
actually deflect us from the truth so
then what happened that was on Thursday
what happened when uh Peter Ducey tried
to ask a follow-up question on Friday
thanks everybody
[Music]
Peter with his hand up over there at the
end yeah she didn't answer any questions
from Peter on uh on that day here's
Peter I believe a day before that asking
Biden directly what he was thinking
classified material
what were you think
let me uh we're going to get a chance to
speak on all this God willing soon but
as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvette's in
the lock garage okay so it's not like
you're sitting out in the streets but
anyway
foreign
yes as well as my Corvette
first off that he thinks his Corvette is
more important than the classified
documents is absolutely hilarious and
either way the documents aren't supposed
to be there it doesn't matter if you put
them in the lock garage next to the
Corvette or rather you put them in your
bedroom under the bed where you keep the
uh the doll that you're sniffing none of
that matters the point is you're not
allowed to have these things in the
first place right by the way I will say
as I said the first day this story broke
it's uh presidents do all sorts of
things and and the way the Machine Works
they all screw up things and bring
things and I don't think Joe Biden was
the one that consciously was like take
those documents put them in the garage
next to the Corvette put the other ones
at the U Penn Center I don't think he
has a freaking clue what's going on but
at some point The Buck has to stop with
somebody and unless the Biden
Administration right now is in a meeting
I mean literally right this second as
we're talking right now unless they're
in a meeting going who's going to take
the Fall For Old Joe here who is going
to be the one that's on the staff are we
going to find the intern or some idiot
who is going or the moving guy who is
going to take the fall and be the one
that's like oh I screwed up I was the
one that literally took documents that
said classified and I put them in the
garage instead of bringing them to
whatever archive they were supposed to
go to et cetera et cetera but you might
be listening to Joe Biden
and going you know the guy does make
sense he's trying the best he can and
you know we should cut him some slack
because he's a good man and and he's a
man who who children love and is
respected by the community you might be
thinking that and I was even thinking
that I was like this is a great man this
Joe Biden we should give him uh the
grant him the leash here he's the
president we want him to do well he has
a great track record with people and and
I wanted to prove it because I believe
that you know we have to give the
Devil's Due it's not I don't want to be
hyper partisan or anything like that so
we found this video you may remember
this one this is a great one of Joe
Biden really just explaining like what
his life has been like and how he
relates to people it's an oldie but it's
a goodie and I think maybe maybe we're
going a little too hard on Old Joe and
by the way you know I sit on the stand
and it get hot I got a lot of I got
hairy legs that turned that that that
that that that that that turn uh
um blonde in the sun and the kids used
to come up and reach in the pool and rub
my leg down so it was traded and then
watched the hair come back up again
they'd look at it so I learned about
roaches I learned about kids jumping on
my lap
and I've Loved kids jumping on my lap
he's a man who loves kids jumping on his
lap so let's give him a little chance
here to can someone explain that clip to
me one more time we have watched that
clip so many times I am to believe that
he was in the pool with these children
he gets his leg wet and when you get
your leg wet your your leg hair is going
to go down a little bit and then in the
sun I guess as it dried the leg hair
would rise okay I can accept all that as
sort of scientific and factual I don't
know why he had other people's children
rubbing his legs but even if I can get
past that can someone explain to me how
that is how he learned about roaches
what does this have to do with roaches
does anyone know what it has to do with
roaches so there's a lot of questions
related to the joke maybe that's what
the classified documents are all about
there could be a classified document in
there it's like Joe Biden's leg hair and
roaches find out the truth
even the corporate press knows that
something stinks here they know that
something stinks and it's getting harder
and harder for them to run cover because
of the internet right because of shows
like this because you can share
information with your aunt and your
cousin and your boss and we can see old
videos and we can expose the hypocrisy
and the rest of it the corporate media
used to have a monopoly on quote-unquote
truth so we it was too late we'd find
out things 10 years later now we're
uncovering and we're unfurling things in
real time so here's Democrat activist
Jake Tapper on CNN and he's even
acknowledging this does not look good
for old Joe he was referring to the the
photograph of the Biden garage I don't
know what your garage looks like but
here's here's the photograph so there's
Biden in his sweet 1967 Stingray but
look on the back left there I don't know
if we can push in there but that looks
like a mess that's worse than my garage
that's worse than my garage I mean
that's not where I don't know exactly
where the documents are in that garage
but that does not look like what a
secure location would be yeah that does
not look like a secure location and it's
also again once again this is the key
part even if it was a secure location
right he still was not allowed to take
the documents that's just how this thing
works so I will give Jake Tapper credit
Jake sometimes the truth is so obvious
even you get it right that's a beautiful
thing but here watch this watch how CNN
as a network is trying to cover for by
they have to cover the story because
it's breaking everywhere even though
they don't want to cover it and it also
because it also makes CNN look
ridiculous right because CNN was pushing
all the lies around the laptop and
everything else so the blaze had an
interesting retweet of a CNN article so
so I'll read the blazes retweet of it
first CNN uses image of Biden receiving
the medal of freedom while trying to
cover for Biden having classified
documents at multiple locations right so
look at the image there that this is
you're supposed to look at this image on
Twitter you kind of just scroll past
things oh and it's Joe Biden there's
Barack Obama and everybody likes Barack
Obama he's a well-spoken dude and he's
putting on a blue ribbon on Joe Biden
they must be doing good things and then
of course the title actually says
something White House AIDS process to
pack up Biden's workspaces was muddled
and hurried as he used his office until
the final minutes of his vice presidency
oh so they were just in Rush guys you
know what I mean they had no idea what
was happening they didn't realize there
was an election and you know you've got
like a month and a half or what is it
almost two months to pack up but these
guys were they were just in a rush go
classify documents we'll get them over
to Joe's Garage with the Corvette I love
that this whole thing's become about a
Corvette the better story here would be
if the Corvette transformed and then
like the deceptive you know who got it
all right whatever uh here's the
lunatics of the view going down a crazy
conspiracy theory related to all this
and then Donald Trump just as we're this
close to getting them but you don't know
here's the thing Biden is wrong to have
done this well let's find it let's find
out what this is first not again one of
the things that gets me crazy is before
we know it's already been spun a
specific way I don't want to see that
the I want to see
someone explained to me a how is
possible that after all this time nobody
knew this because to me if you missing
classified information I don't be
laughing in my house if stuff is missing
I know it's supposed to be like apple
research to you does it feel like the
Republicans are behind it
did originally but I'm sorry but not not
now because one of the things one of the
things he's saying is that you know some
of these some of the locations where the
docs may have been shipped in the
transition I may have gotten taken and
put but still
this whoopee
um I'm sure you'd be saying the exact
same thing if this was Donald Trump
right like if we were to just flash back
to August and September and find the uh
the clips of you guys talking about
Donald Trump and his classified doctor
oh it must be a Democrat talking point
and we should wait to see and it's a
plant and all that stuff and joy joy who
the wrestling has obviously been
injected directly in her brain okay
that's the filler interface obviously
like one of the one little injection
just went right into her brain she
thinks that the machine is somehow
defending Trump that the machine was
about to get Trump and then at the last
second they were like no we're gonna get
Biden
I they who uh so a little more of now
what's actually happening here why Biden
is actually in trouble because there
actually is a special counsel uh now
looking into this so we've got a little
bit of info on that uh breaking attorney
general Garland that's Merrick Garland
says he has appointed former U.S
attorney Robert Herr as special counsel
to investigate Biden documents matter
okay so where does this all put us look
Joe Biden from day one of announcing his
presidency began with a lot you may
remember this and actually we'll play
this for you tomorrow in Joe Biden's
intro video when he said he was running
for president he said the reason he was
running was because of Donald Trump and
Charlottesville very fine people on both
sides that was a hoax okay so he ran
because of a hoax Donald Trump
immediately condemned the White
supremacists and the neo-nazis we've
covered this a million times here the
mainstream media refuses to cover it but
the the Genesis the beginning of why
we're on this idiotic adventure with
this Mr Magoo character was a lie okay
that's number one number two when you
take just the General State of lying and
also how he found out about roaches and
the kids in the pool and then you throw
in the dementia and you throw in the
corruption related to his son and that
there was obviously some level of money
laundering and firing the prosecutor in
the Ukraine and all of that stuff it
ain't good so let's just talk a little
bit about the hunt der Biden corruption
specifically we've got some info here
from the daily wire President Joe
Biden's son Hunter had his salary cut by
the Ukrainian Energy company that put
him on their board while Joe Biden
served as Barack Obama's vice president
just two months after the end of the
Obama Administration my God I can't
believe it while Joe Biden was vice
president Hunter Biden was paid 83 Grand
a month to sit on barisma's board after
the new agreement was signed his
compensation was slashed by half to 41
000. to be sure still an exorbitant
monthly sum for someone with no
qualifications to sit on the board but
far less than the million dollar a year
salary he was commanding so just one
more time for any of you that have
gotten a job out there would you think
it was a little odd if you had no
qualifications for a job and someone
gave you 80 grand a month about a
million dollars a year to sit on a board
which you don't have to do a lot of work
when you're sitting on a board if you
had no qualifications but then it turned
out that they just wanted to get to your
dad who was extremely influential now if
your dad was a a ditch digger that would
be considered odd right but if your dad
was vice president it wouldn't be so odd
a little bit more from the daily wire
Hunter Biden arranged multiple business
deals with close allies of Chinese
presidents jizing jingpin squeezing 6
million out of the relationship before
things went sour Hunter's association
with the Chinese allegedly comes through
a Business Partnership he opened with
the Chinese energy fund committee cefc
was the capitalist arm of President
jinping's imperious imperialist belt and
Road initiative to export Chinese
influence around the world rights Devine
any cooperation with cefc expanded
China's despotic Global hegemony and the
Biden's bank accounts at the cost of U.S
Nash National Security through 2015 and
2016 Hunter and his Partners had been
using the Biden name to open doors for
cefc around the world in Kazakhstan
Georgia Oman Ukraine Romania and Beyond
so Hunter creates this other company it
was a giant money laundering operation
that was either done with Joe Biden's
direct knowledge
or his son was using him in either case
we got a problem here okay so let's
let's just say I've made a roughly
decent case that something between the
hunter Biden laptop classified documents
Biden business dealings with China
through Ukraine and everything else
let's just say that there's something
there if you've been watching the show
you Michael Dave you've been babbling on
about God knows what but I'll grant you
that there's a little something there
well what else has Joe Biden done that
is worth at this point getting rid of
this guy and I think that's sort of
what's Happening Here the machine is now
realizing we don't need him anymore what
what the machine needed Biden for was to
get rid of trump it needed to get all of
the other Democrats bootage and
Elizabeth Warren and everybody else that
needed them all to fall in line so we
could get him in get rid of trump and
now they're realizing between the
scandals and the cognitive stuff and
what's going on with the economy and
everything else that this just ain't
working and I think they are showing him
the door but there are many reasons they
should show him the door here is Joe
Biden back in September of 2021
announcing vaccine mandates vaccine
mandates which were anti-constitutional
against your right to Medical privacy
free speech and a whole bunch more
remember this this is not about Freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you
the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love
my job as president is to protect all
Americans
so tonight I'm announcing that the
Department of Labor is developing an
emergency rule to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week
already I've announced we'll be
requiring vaccinations at all nursing
home workers who treat patients on
Medicare and Medicaid because I have
that Federal Authority
tonight I'm using that same Authority to
expand that to cover those who work in
hospitals Home Health Care Facilities or
other medical facilities
a total of 17 million health care
workers
I will sign an executive order that will
now require all executive branch federal
employees to be vaccinated all
I've signed another executive order that
will require Federal contractors to do
the same if you want to work with the
federal government and do business to
this get vaccinated
okay so almost everything that he said
there turned out to be actually
anti-constitutional courts reversed it
the OSHA mandate was reversed it was all
nonsense and that actually it's hard to
remember because the every the news goes
by so fast everything changes so quickly
these days but that back in September of
2021 when he said that thing about the
hundred employees that was like the
final straw for me that was the nail on
the coffin so to speak in terms of
whether I was going to get the vaccine
or not and I was 100 sure at that point
that I was not going to get it because I
was sitting in a room with a couple
other people a few of them are in this
room with me right now and the idea that
oh if you have a hundred employees then
you have some sort of right as an
employer to force people to inject
things into their bodies for the luxury
of working for you now I don't have a
hundred employees but the very idea that
I would have the right to tell anyone
what they can you inject yourself with
some chlorine now you reject yourself
with some Kool-Aid it's so crazy so but
that's what he was for and when he said
at the beginning this is not about
Freedom or personal choice yes it damn
well was and it damn well is now I think
you can absolutely argue that he was in
violation of his oath of office which is
to protect the Constitution of the
United States as he was trampling on the
Bill of Rights and our right to personal
freedom and medical privacy and all of
those things and also at the end there
when he said that thing about his job is
to protect us your job Joe Biden is not
to protect me okay your job is to stay
the F out of my life that's all I ask of
you stay out of my life it would be nice
if you could protect the borders I know
you can't do that but your job certainly
is not to protect me and it is
definitely not to protect me from a
disease that was hyped up and basically
an entire conspiracy theory the entire
time
okay let's talk about the Border because
I think you get it there was some sort
of Scandal here Ukraine something
something the way he handled covid
absolutely horrible infringement on
rights what about the border at the very
least I would imagine the man is
handling the border right I mean
presidents borders something here's some
info from statista uh here is as you can
see the hockey stick type uh graph right
there an enormous
spike in illegal border crossings under
Joe Biden's presidency we know that
millions and millions of illegal
immigrants not migrants not happy joyous
people uh not decent citizens to be but
illegal immigrants often criminals
people that are bringing fentanyl over
the border and a whole bunch more that
when you see that that's what they call
the hockey stick when it goes hockey
stick right there you don't want the
hockey stick when it comes to something
bad you do if you're say building a tech
company uh users hockey stick that's
good that type of hockey stick you don't
want uh but okay the Border fine uh what
about what about the economic conditions
has he done a good job related to that
we've got more from statista we're we're
a graph Sharon show today uh this is
inflation uh under Joe Biden and as you
can see there is a massive Spike
inflation up up up up up but I will give
the devil is due it's gone down a tiny
teeny tiny bit lately uh but overall it
is way up and you don't need a graph to
figure that out are you paying more for
things at the grocery store I went I
sent I tweeted a picture of it this
weekend I went to buy eggs at Whole
Foods there was a sign in the egg area
saying that be due to the National egg
shortage you can only get two cartons of
eggs that's happening not in Soviet
Russia in 1986 it is now happening in
America in 2023. I would welcome you as
I often say because we're just now
redoing our one of the rooms over here
so we can turn into an office for the
staff go to Crate and Barrel or CB2 or
West Elm or wherever you buy furniture
pick a random couch and see how long it
takes to deliver because of the supply
chain issues that are directly related
to the economic conditions that this guy
brought in it was not happening under
Trump and believe it or not Trump had
was president during that covid thing
too okay so what do we need what do we
need look
it seems obvious to me that the machine
is done with Biden one way or another
they realize he cannot run again
either because of the scandals or
because of the ineptitude or because
they've just they used him for what they
needed him for or they think he is going
to break down mentally they are figuring
a way to show him the door uh the the
people the NPCs the joy behars of the
thing will somehow always double down
and this will prove that America is an
evil white patriarchal something
something all that stuff but the machine
itself is done with Joe Biden he's on
his way out it's it's just obvious so
the question is what do we do going
forward right because you know look
whether they bump Kamala up or they
bring in Gavin Newsom or whatever it is
it's obviously going to get worse the
Democrat machine will always always get
worse and it will always have the people
protecting it as it gets worse so those
of us that are Freedom loving those of
us that love America those of us that
want to continue this thing we got work
to do but I am as I said last week and
it's why we did that show all on
positive news I think that was on
Thursday
I am bullish on America and that might
be because I live here in the Free State
of Florida I think that's the first time
I said Florida in a half hour that might
be a record
um but there is a lot of good stuff
happening and there is a mass Awakening
where people are not buying the BS
anymore so we got a chance so Dr Robert
Malone you know Dr Robert Malone he is
the inventor and owns more uh patents on
mRNA technology than anyone he was the
guy that went viral in that in that
famous clip with Joe Rogan uh so you
have to understand this this is the guy
who basically invented mRNA technology
who has now become the world's leading
skeptic of mRNA technology right he is
warning people there is some bad stuff
going on with all this stuff well he's
also been talking about what do we have
to do on the other side of this thing
how do we build new things how do we
escape the globalist plot that seems to
have been hatched against us and with
those whack jobs at the wef are doing in
Davos right now we'll do more on that
tomorrow well Robert Malone had a tweet
that I thought was quite interesting
that could help bring us home here he
said how can people develop a new way
forward without falling into the same
traps which have given rise to the
totalitarian Marxist corporatist fascist
globalist Vision being promoted and
shaped by the world economic forum and
its affiliates that's the question how
can we do it if if some of us see what's
going on here
how like how do you stop Goliath well
David stopped Goliath
so maybe Dave could stop the world
economic Forum that's how I'm viewing
this thing I think we can do it we just
need more and more people to step up and
be brave and stop participating in the
lie and do whatever you can in your life
to
stop it it's as simple as that it really
is as simple as that and then when you
do that then you start that that that
bravery thing starts spreading and then
people start saying hey you know what
I'll run for this I'll get on a school
board I'll defend my kids I'm not going
to buy this BS from the media and
everything else and then you start
getting good politicians and we've got a
couple as I've been saying the
Republicans in the house now are
suddenly uh showing that they're gonna
fight this is good Ron Johnson at the
beginning fighting Chuck Todd on his
ground exposing Chuck Todd for what it
he is and then of course there is this
guy right here in Florida Ron DeSantis
here he is explaining how he will hold
Disney accountable for what they did and
actually how this is connected to
everything that we've discussed over the
last 40 minutes or so so um you know
what I said was last year uh that Disney
will no longer have its own government
Disney will live under the same laws as
everybody else and Disney will pay the
debts and taxes and that's exactly
what's going to happen so the question
was always is it going to be under State
control or local control I actually
initially when we did the bill to Sunset
it and we knew we were going to take
additional action I was agnostic between
those but then what started happening
was you at Orange County saying they
were going to raise people's taxes by
thousands of dollars and doing this now
I think that was all a dog and pony show
but then I'm thinking to myself is that
really something that that I want to uh
allow them to be able to do do I trust
them being able to handle the Municipal
debt and all this stuff and so I'm not I
I'm not I don't have a lot of confidence
in that so it's going to be a state
control board there's absolutely
[Applause]
there's absolutely going to be
accountability uh the corporate Kingdom
has come to an end and that will be the
case when this is enacted
[Applause]
look whether it is fighting the ideas of
the world economic forum and one
government to rule us all one ring to
rule us all or whether it's the governor
of Florida going after one of the giant
corporations in the world and you may
remember you may remember this is less
than a year ago with this whole don't
say gay nonsense came out and Disney was
going all in on trying to destroy
DeSantis and everything else everybody
in the mainstream media was siding with
Disney and saying you can't defeat
Disney and this is going to hurt
DeSantis at The Ballot Box because
they're in Orlando and they have 30 000
employees in Florida or something like
that and you can't fight their money and
you can't fight their influence and he
did it and he won by 20 points Disney
stock is crashing they're coming
crawling back to him Bob Iger the new
CEO who replaced the guy Bob chapic who
was who was basically us hostage from
his woke employees Iger is now reversing
course on some of what they're doing
with their programming so you can win
but you got to get involved whatever
that means to you
I'm going to say a 9-8 this Monday gosh
darn it fellas and ladies we've done a
fine job sorry sorry Daphne freaked out
when I said I thought with the gender
these days I thought it was you know all
right uh stick around for a cold close
in just a moment uh oh it's me Monday
over at the Reuben report locals
Community here's the one that I posted
this morning don't worry the doors are
always locked Joe Biden so we got a
couple hundred people putting their
memes in there uh we are now as of today
guys we are closing the post game show
so it'll only be for locals members you
can join at reubenreport.locals.com if
you join annually uh you get two months
free otherwise it's five bucks a month
and you get extra content you get
ad-free stuff I post some videos I
posted some videos of the kids this
morning like it's just a little more of
a personal way to do things and you get
the post game show where people can
correct me if I screwed something up or
you can ask me questions directly
comments your thoughts all of that good
stuff I think the way we're going to do
it starting today is that the first 30
seconds will always be uh available and
then we we click a button what is it a
button or a slider or a it's a some sort
of slider that he has over there on his
computer machine and then it is only for
paid subscribers so you can join us at
Ruben
report.locals.com my full interview with
Tulsi gabbard is up all over the place
and I will be back
momentarily
[Music]
and so it's basically like there's
scientific consensus
that the lives of children are going to
be very difficult and it does lead I
think young people to
have a legitimate question you know
should
is it okay to still have children
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]